let's do some example problems using our
newly acquired knowledge of isosceles
and equilateral triangles so over here I
have a kind of a triangle within a
triangle and we need to figure out this
orange angle right over here and this
blue angle right over here and we know
that side a B is equal to our segment a
B is equal to segment BC which is equal
to segment CD or we could also call that
DC so first of all we see that triangle
triangle ABC is isosceles and because
it's isosceles the two base angles are
going to be congruent this is one leg
this is the other leg right over there
so the two base angles are going to be
congruent so we know that this angle
right over here is also 31 degrees well
if we know two of the angles in a
triangle we can always figure out the
third angle they have to add up to 180
degrees
so if we call we could say 31 degrees
plus 31 degrees plus the measure of
angle ABC ABC is equal to 180 degrees
you can subtract 60 to this right here
62 degrees
you subtract 62 from both sides you get
the measure of angle ABC is equal to
let's see 180 minus sixty would be 120
you subtract another two you get 118
degrees so this angle right over here is
one hundred 118 degrees let me just
write like this well this is 118 degrees
well this angle right over here this
angle right over here is supplementary
to that 118 degrees so that angle plus
118 is going to be equal to 180 we
already know that that's 62 degrees 62
plus 118 is 180 so this right over here
is 60 this right over here is 62 degrees
now this angle is one of the base angles
for triangle BCD I didn't draw it that
way but this side and this side are
congruent BC has the same length as CD
those are the two legs of an isosceles
triangle you can kind of imagine it was
turned upside down this is the vertex
this is one base angle this is the other
base
well the base angles are going to be
congruent so this is going to be 62
degrees as well and then finally if you
want to figure out this blue angle the
the blue angle plus these two 62 degree
angles are going to have to add up to
180 degrees so you get 62 plus 62 plus
the blue angle which is the measure of
angle BCD measure of angle BCD is going
to have to be equal to 180 degrees these
two characters let's see 62 plus 62 is
124 you subtract 124 from both sides you
get the measure of angle B C D is equal
to let's see if you subtract 120 you get
60 and then you have to subtract another
4 so you get 50 you get 56 degrees so
this is equal to 56 degrees and we're
done now let's we could do either of
these let's do this one right over here
so what is the measure of angle a b e so
they haven't even drawn segment to be he
here so let me draw that for us and so
we have to figure out the measure of
angle a b e so we have a bunch of
congruent segments here and in
particular we see that triangle abd all
of its sides are equal so it's an
equilateral triangle which means all of
the angles are equal and if all of the
angles are equal in a triangle they all
have to be 60 degrees they all have to
be 60 degrees so that all of these
characters are going to be 60 degrees
well that's part of angle a be e but we
have to figure out this other part right
over here and to do that we can see that
we're actually dealing with an isosceles
triangle kind of kind of tipped over to
the left this is the vertex angle this
is one base angle this is the other base
angle and the vertex angle right here is
90 degrees and once again we notice
isosceles because this side segment BD
is equal to segment de and once again
these two angles Plus this angle right
over here is going to have to add up to
90 degrees so you call that an X you
call that an X you get X plus X plus 90
is going to be 180 degrees so you get 2x
plus let me just write it out I want to
skip steps here we have X plus
X plus 90 is going to be equal to 180
degrees X plus X is the same thing as 2x
plus 90 is equal to 180 and then we can
subtract 90 from both sides you get 2x
is equal to 90 or divide both sides by 2
you get X is equal to 45 X is equal to
45 degrees and then we're done because
angle a B E is going to be equal to the
60 degrees plus the 45 degrees so it's
going to be this whole angle which is
what we care about angle a B E is going
to be a plus 45 which is 105 degrees and
now we have this last problem over here
this one looks a little bit simpler I
have an isosceles triangle this leg is
equal to that leg this is the vertex and
I know I have to figure out B and the
trick here is like wait how do I figure
out one side of a triangle if I only
know one other side or not I need to
know two other sides and we'll do it the
exact same way we just did that second
part of that problem if this is an
isosceles triangle which we know it is
then this angle is going to be equal to
that angle there and so if we call this
X then this is X as well we get X plus X
plus 36 degrees plus 36 is equal to 180
the two X's when you add them up you get
2x and then I'll just I won't skip the
steps here 2x plus 36 is equal to 180
subtract 36 from both sides we get 2x 2x
that 2 looks a little bit funny we get
2x is equal to 180 minus 30 is 150 and
then you want to subtract another 6 from
150 gets us to 144 did I do that right
180 minus 30 is 150 yep 144 divide both
sides by 2 you get X is equal to 72
degrees so this is equal to 72 degrees
and we are done